with this much pressure being exerted on
our society at all times a lot of public
figures just give up and become pathetic
herd animals but some of them become a
lot more impressive much deeper and more
profound and speaking of that Tulsi
gabbard posted this video online today
we saw it we thought you might want to
also here it is
today's self-proclaimed feminists will
not Define what a woman is and are
unfortunately actively seeking to erase
the progress that Title IX has made over
the last 50 years by essentially trying
to erase women as an entire category of
people
well that's right I mean that's what's
going on underneath the headlines and so
we wanted to ask Chelsea gabbard more
about it she's a former member of
Congress of course ran for president and
we're happy to have her tonight thank
you so much for coming on so why why did
you say this what was it in response to
and how long have you been thinking
about this
oh this this has been an ongoing issue
Tucker as you know I served in Congress
for eight years and this has been
something that's building and growing
over time I introduced legislation
bipartisan legislation while I was in
Congress out of a recognition of this
problem that we have people who claim to
be feminists yet who are exercising the
height of hypocrisy by actually trying
to erase women as an entire category of
people and doing so by by doing things
like the Biden Administration is doing
now in trying to undo Title IX the
legislation that was enacted 50 years
ago out of a recognition of the
difference in biological sex between men
and women and boys and girls and so my
legislation very simply called the
protect women's sports act upheld that
original intent of Title IX ensuring
that Sports would be maintained with
that original intent with females
competing against females males
competing against males and so the video
I posted this morning was part of a
podcast interview that I did with one of
the nation's top female swimmers Riley
Gaines who has direct experience of the
consequences of what this Administration
is doing in that she was forced to
compete against a biological male for
the national championship and how uh
basically how she was sidelined in the
interest of this fear uh filled culture
where you've just got to go along to get
along no matter the fact that you're
actually denying the existence of
objective truth that you've got a 6'4
male with male parts competing and
swimming against women in college and
being given the podium and the medal
while the women are being sidelined it
really is a crashing defeat for what we
were told feminism was and I have to
wonder I mean it's the opposite as
always of what they claim it is do you
have any sense of the motive behind this
why would anyone want to do this
uh it's a great question uh the people
who are propagating this I'm sure they
have their own motives that that go
actually much deeper than this issue of
denying women denying motherhood trying
to actually change our language so that
we actually erase the word woman and
mother and sister from our our
vocabulary the underlying danger here is
the denial of objective truth and once
we as a society allow this to occur that
we no longer believe that what is true
is true then what we're left with is No
Boundaries no moral boundaries and those
in power being in a position where they
and only they Define and tell us what is
true and what is false and we end up
with pure insanity yes they're God in
other words and they Define what reality
exactly that is so smart
former congresswoman Chelsea gabbard
tonight thank you so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else